so first of all I like to thank students
for liberty oven to invite me tonight
well actually it's an afternoon to just
speak to you just a first question who
actually knows has never even heard of
me in this room
okay that's like about maybe 1/4 so my
thanks is because I I was it came at an
opportune time because I was getting a
bit worried that like my little 15
minutes of fame were going to be spent
on talking about Pepe the Frog and so
it's actually happy to be here for those
who don't know what that means you'll
get to to understand that as my talk
goes on so about a year ago everybody
saw what happened with what I guess
we'll call the pronoun gate with Jordan
Peterson and before that I was a pretty
a political person you know I mean yeah
I was a pretty a political person just
living my life and I had met Jordan
Peterson because I had heard some of
some of his talks and it was like a year
before I'd heard a lot so I'm his talks
and his ideas connected so much with
mine that I was just excited by what he
was saying and I and I got to know him
and we we became friends and all of a
sudden this thing hit and here I was
watching someone that I knew all of a
sudden watching someone that was one of
the most authentic and genuine people I
had ever met being dragged in the mud
being slandered you know being called a
Nazi when he was for the last 30 years
of his life he spent his time fighting
the spirit that could lead someone to
become a Nazi and it was really it was
really mind-blowing and it what it did
is it opened my eyes all of a sudden and
I started to see things I guess you
would say that I was read pilled to use
the word that all you young
whippersnappers use there and all the
sudden I started to see the the network
of manipulation of ideas that was at
least in some strands of the media and I
started to see how so many of the
stories were ideologically driven I mean
obviously I kind of seen most people
have kind of noticed that in the back of
their mind or noticed it you know in the
periphery but then I I was being kind of
thrust into it because someone I knew
was actually going through the process
of being dragged through this and so
what happened is during that crazy time
for some reason Jordan asked me to do an
interview on his channel and so because
in life I'm an icon Carver I'm someone
who's interested in symbolism in general
that's what connected me with Jordan I
couldn't help but interpret what he was
going through through the lens of
symbolism and so we did this this video
together called the metaphysics of Pepe
and then since then it's been absolutely
insane Jordan is he's not his fault but
he dragged me down into this rabbit hole
and I'm just been kind of following
through and
and and and in doing what I can to to
speak forthrightly let's say and to to
to say things to notice what's happening
and and to talk about it and so it
became obvious to me that even the CBC
even like the big media organizations
they were in a very strange situation
but also in general like this the kind
of mainstream media you know they was it
was coming to a point where they would
give you the news in two minute segments
you know clickbait articles and they
would just draw the line real straight
in a short article so that you knew
exactly what to think
exactly how to see the world and as all
of this was going and maybe through what
Jordan was going through I started to
notice this whole crew of people coming
out of internet culture this whole group
of people and then I was you know people
were putting or putting out these one
hour two hour three hour podcasts and it
was this just a smear reflection of the
debate that you know the clickbait in
two minute segments and people were
paying attention people who are
listening to you know the most listen to
podcasts in the world is three hours
long so the idea is what is happening so
hopefully this talk I'm going to try to
trace using images and stories try to
help you to understand how is it that we
came to the spot where we're in right
now how it is that we have most people
have this strange feeling that the world
is upside down how did that happen how
is how is it that how is it that people
who are trying to say reasonable things
are being treated as if they're crazy
marginal you know off completely off the
track thinkers
and so as someone who's interested in
symbols and in symbolism I'm someone
who's attentive to stories I see
patterns I look for patterns and stories
and I look for patterns in how things
emerge and and one of the reasons that
made me want to get involved and to
start to speak out and to to to become I
guess socially involved is because I
started to see patterns we could say
patterns of the end of something there
are things that happen when something
ends whatever it is whether it's it's a
human life whether it's a friendship
whatever identity you can imagine there
are certain things that happen and those
things can be can be traced you can see
what that looks like and they can be
compared at different levels of
manifestation and so I know that saying
that that way is very abstract or what I
mean I'm going to try to give you an
example of a world and show you how that
works and hopefully you'll be able to
see what it looks like right now and so
when you're trying to give an example of
a metaphysical structure like my rule of
thumb is the the best the first thing
you need the first example you use is to
use superheroes it's like rule number
one so that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna take give take you through the
weird story of Superman and show you how
that world develops and how it works and
how it's an image of any world really so
let's take this idea of Superman first
superhero it's a great idea right alien
being comes to the Earth from a
destroyed world has all these
superpowers becomes a hero has a really
nice neat costume and so very simple
basic idea so I want you to imagine this
idea as let's say a spark or a golden
ball that's being dropped in a pond of
water
it's an idea you drop this pound
this golden ball into a pond of water so
it's like this idea of Superman is
dropped into the collective imagination
so what happens is there's these waves
that start to grow out of that contact
between that spark and the world that
spark and the pond and the waves start
to grow out of that contact and the
rings get bigger and bigger so you put
out a comic book every month for like 20
years what do you do right
you take that basic idea and you expand
it Superman what Superman Oh Superman is
this okay so he fights this big evil
thing he you know he protects us from
this other thing and then his
relationship started to develop his
relationship starts to become more
complex but at some point you run out of
those ideas right I mean there's so many
things you can do so that would be like
it's the end of the Golden Age of
Superman so what do you what do you do
you eat the Apple in the garden you mean
because you're bored right you're bored
you know you you feel like you've seen
it all you need to see something more
and so you eat the apple you become self
conscious and you find a way to stand up
and then look at this from the outside
to look at this ideas from the outside
and you say okay well so we have
Superman so what if Superman was a girl
so have Supergirl and what if Superman
was a like a little boy so you have
Superboy then you keep going and then
all of a sudden you're like what if
Superman was a dog yeah we have Superdog
Krypto the Superdog and usually in any
human process by the time you reach dog
you're like scratching at the limit okay
you have to pull back there's a reason
why dogs are the guardians of hell it's
not arbitrary so you have to pull back
but you don't be maybe you can't you
don't know how so you keep going and
then by the time you reach like streaky
the super cat like you're finished so
that's a real thing by the way streaky
the super cat
and then after a while like you have you
have like Superman had this like town of
miniature Kryptonians in his like lair
and then he had this like huge army of
of like bad
Kryptonians who were his enemies and
then he had like an army of robots which
looked exactly like him which were
flying around the world in like saving
the world like as much as he is so it's
like you know it's like the world is
drowning in like Superman at some point
Superman is like just one amongst all
these super things all these
idiosyncrasies and it comes to a point
even where like all the superheroes are
just a knockoffs of Superman and they
get more complex and more subtle and
then we look back and we see Superman or
like how boring is he like he's just so
obvious like so straightforward and
boring there came a time when even his
superpowers became so like precise he
was a super ventriloquist and then like
like a super hypnotist and he could like
move planets and go back in time and
like you know go through dimensions and
it's like what do you do there's nothing
left to do
you're yet filled the Superman world to
its limit there's nothing left to do
and all these idiosyncrasies are there
on the edge and you have to think of it
I'm really describing a world do you
guys know how in the Middle Ages they
describe the world that's exactly how
they describe the world if you ever seen
a map of the world in the Middle Ages
you had the center of the map usually
was Jerusalem and then all the
continents would flow out of that Center
and then on the edge of the world what
was on the edge of the world
all these idiosyncrasies people with
just one leg people with heads in their
chests and like all these monsters that
were like absurd self-referential things
and idiosyncrasies that existed
on the border of the world once you get
to that end there's not much left to do
but there is on one last thing that can
happen when you reach the edge of a
world and that's the opposite the end of
an identity is its opposite so what's
the end of the Superman world the end of
the Superman world is bizarro Superman
he's an upside-down Superman he does
everything upside down
so everything Superman does he's like a
mirror reflection and he's like the edge
of the Superman world and on the
medieval map at the edge of the world
there were the man-eating monsters the
cannibals are on the edge of the world
or the upside-down world the world where
the Amazons live where the women are
warriors and the men are barely there
and so that's you know there's a there's
a reason why we are where we are now and
Marx knew this right March he knew in in
in identifying his story of emancipation
he knew that the end of emancipation is
not equality the end of emancipation of
the classes is the tyranny of the
proletariat that's not the same thing so
if the end of Christianity is the
Antichrist if the end of Superman is
bizarro Superman that's how the world
works
and it's only after you've reached that
upside-down Ness then things are
finished and then the world has to
reboot so what do you do what do you do
when you get there well let's look at
the Superman story what do you do so
imagine now again that ball that falls
down into the water
and makes these waves as the waves go
out they become more and more and they
began to fragment and they begin to
break apart and then finally they
dissolve okay so what can you do the
only thing you can do is you dive back
into the origin you go down into the
water and you find that golden ball that
first spark you pull it out of the water
and you start the cycle again so in
terms of marketing we call that
rebooting the franchise and in terms of
let's say what Jordan Peterson says he
calls it going down into the water and
saving your dead father from the belly
of the whale and that way you avert a
total apocalypse you restart with the
origin you create a new hierarchy based
on the on the basic elements of what
created that thing in the first place
whatever it is just using Superman as an
example you create a new hierarchy and
you prune all the things which are too
idiosyncratic which are too odd and
don't you know or too much on the
margins and you come back to something
that brings it together
so a lot of you might think what I just
described is weird because using stories
a lot of you more rational engineer
types just struggle with what I just
said so I'm gonna give you one last
example of this process but I'm gonna
give it I'm gonna give you one that is
that is as technical as I could think of
now imagine you're in a large room and
there are 1 million buttons in your room
and your job is to sort the buttons
right and your job is to sort the
buttons between two bins there's a green
bin and there's a blue bin and you have
to sort the buttons so you start start
sorting the buttons your green button
putting the green bin see a blue button
put it in the blue bin you keep going
and one of them once in a while you see
a button that you're not quite sure or
you're not quite sure exactly where it
goes but it doesn't matter because
you've got a million buttons to store to
you just ignore it
you keep going keep sorting the buttons
I don't know how long it would take you
probably years to sort the buttons and
then you keep going and then you see
another button that doesn't totally
quite fit and then maybe one time you
see a red button you're like what
exactly is that doing there but no I
mean it doesn't matter you just keep
going because you've got so many to sort
and at some point you come to a time
let's say to a time where you have 1000
buttons and you can't sort them anymore
all of them don't fit there's some kind
of weird blue green or green blue or
they're too dark or they're too light or
maybe they're just red or yellow and you
you don't know what to do
if you don't have a way to handle
exceptions if you don't have a category
in your system which is just exception
you're in serious trouble because a
thousand buttons is still a lot of
buttons and then those buttons are the
ones that are screaming at you sort me
out so what do you do well there's a few
things you can do if you don't have a
category called exception one thing you
might do is you might create 1,000 bins
for the 1,000 buttons one button per bin
that'd be a nice way to do it
now maybe we need 100 bathrooms in every
building and we'd be fine
maybe you're such a crisis that now
these 1000 buttons are screaming so loud
that you start to question the very
categories that you use to sort the nine
hundred and ninety-nine thousand buttons
and you start to say well actually maybe
there actually isn't a difference
between blue and green because I've got
a thousand buttons and they're neither
and then suddenly every idiosyncratic
possibility every exception becomes this
new reference this new inverted Center
and that's what's happening right now we
are at I would say it that way let's say
that our civilization is running out of
gas and we are seeing some very strange
phenomena because of that and what we're
seeing is the last gasps let's say of
the whole
modern project of emancipation / control
that came through the West and in your
history classes most of you they will
have not said emancipation / control
they will have told you emancipation
they will have most history classes even
today they will tell you that the whole
modern project from the Renaissance to
the Enlightenment all of that is just a
series of emancipations where people are
freeing themselves from the control of
the Church of the aristocracy and then
you know the control of religion in
general etc etc but in fact the the each
of those emancipations has a shadow
control to it each liberation was
accompanied by an equal centralization
of power the humanism of the renaissance
brought about the beginning of real
realpolitik in Machiavelli those two
things happen at the same time the
Reformation brought about the first
nation states the first borders those
two things are just two sides of the
same coin the French Revolution brought
the Emperor Napoleon and down the line
all the revolutions and tyrannies of the
20th century and just now finally the
Arab Spring that everybody told us the
Arab Spring the Arab Spring it's amazing
and I was sitting in my couch saying you
nut jobs what do you think is going to
happen and then suddenly everybody
doesn't understand why there's this
attempt to create a new caliphate it was
right there you should have seen it
coming it's always the same story and
now we've reached you know if that
project of emancipation were a purrito
distribution and now we all know because
of Jordan Peterson what a preeto
distribution is if if it was that
we are reaching this point where it goes
up strikes up dramatically we've reached
the singularity of emancipation /
control because it's no longer just to
be freed from the church from the state
you know from from these these these
social hierarchies but the desire to be
freed from offensive words and
microaggressions basically to be freed
from any ambiguity not only in fact but
in intention the desire to be free not
only from your violent words but your
violent thoughts towards me and the last
upside-down contradiction which appears
in this project is that we've seen this
this this crazy upside down hierarchy of
victimhood where the person who can
accumulate the most minority the most
marginal identity who can tell the most
stories of being the victim now becomes
the unquestioned emperor of all and this
leads to its own upside-down absolute
authority which legislates differences
which wants to reprogram
your implicit thoughts to make sure that
we bow down to this new hierarchy not
only an action but in thought you cannot
get more extreme than that and the and
the internet you know that that great
promise of absolute freedom right that's
what they told us the internet is going
to be the most freedom that everybody
has anybody has ever seen in the history
of the world and now we are finding out
that from search to email to social
media it is also a system of control
where all your interactions are recorded
forever it seems and can be searched
two can be searched through through
algorithms algorithms and BOTS in order
to manage even your private
relationships we have no idea how far
that will go
but when Zuckerberg is boasting about
creating a mind-reading social network
we should all be very afraid
at how our systems of informations with
which promised us the greatest Liberty
in the history of humanity is actually
becoming a tool of ideological control
the likes of which humanity has never
seen in its entire history and now and
I'm not saying that either emancipation
or control are bad things in themselves
it's only when they are taken to their
extreme when they're seen in their
extremes it's only when the head of the
serpent has reached its tail and the
thing you want it turns into the very
thing it's very opposite and you don't
even realize that it's happening and
that's what we're seeing around us right
now you see one of the things that
happens at the end of a process when you
reach the end of something there's a
fight between something being complete
and something being coherent that's the
story of the buttons that's what the
story of the buttons is about but it's
also the story of I don't know drinking
a nice craft beer you drink your beer
and then you come to the dregs what do
you do do you drink the dregs or do you
don't not drink the dregs if you don't
drink the dregs did you drink the beer
and if you do drink the dregs well you
go through the bitterness we're seeing
that being play out we've seen it
already been played out in modern times
that is either a desire to arrive at a
world where everything is ordered and
all is logically structured purity
perfection no exceptions the margin is
cut off and that was Nazism or else we
have a desire to create a world without
margin without hierarchy where all are
included and all are equal no exceptions
and that was communism and both ideas
are absolutely murderous those two
realities the complete and that coherent
they're real ideals right in a way there
are the two basic poles of being and it
just can't be brushed aside but we're
meant to live in the middle of those two
opposites we're meant to mediate those
two opposites but when we see those two
opposites rear their heads again in the
world well it's just one more sign that
the world is falling apart falling apart
and solidifying completely at the same
time and it's very odd but I know that
everybody here can get examples in their
mind in a second of how those two things
are happening at the same time right in
the only solution the only solution is
is to dive is to dive into that dark
place to find to get that golden ball
find the seed the thing which boasts
both binds us together and opens up unto
growth at the same time which binds us
together but also opens up into
variability and difference so who who
does that who can do that who can dive
down into the waters and find that
now there's a story of Gilgamesh and
Enkidu Gilgamesh was the great
Mesopotamian king of Uruk and he was a
tyrant in his own way and his tyranny
was only balanced out when he united
himself to like a brother to Anki do and
Anki do is the wild man
he's the Savage half beast half monster
he came out of the forest to confront
Gilgamesh in his abuses and it's the
union of those two opposites which
creates a viable civilization so one day
the King drops his ball and his mallet
into the underworld but it's not the
king who goes to get it rather it's the
Beast hybrid Enkidu who descends into
death and finally returns after much
travail and the help of the gods with
the ball so it is the hybrid it's the
monster it's it's the the trickster who
gets the ball it's the thief Aladdin who
finds the land
Bilbo has to become a thief before he
finds the Arkenstone in the cave of the
dragon you see the marginal trickster
character right that character is the
character that uses these limits uses
these ambiguous idiosyncratic things you
know he's a shapeshifter
he changes shapes he's disguised he uses
these in-between spaces of the world to
get what he wants he uses inversion to
reach his goals but at the edge of the
world at the end of the world when the
world is already upside down what is a
trickster to do well the only thing that
the trickster can do is to restore the
center
is to put the world back on its feet
when the Greeks made a bloody mess of
the Trojan War and the whole thing is
sealed with rape and infanticide and
sacrilege and secret trickery it is then
paradoxically the trickster himself
Ulysses who himself is the one who came
up with the solution of the Trojan horse
to enter into Troy it is that very
trickster who is now able to go back
home and restore order in his house in
Ithaca so we can see it in the stories
it's there in the stories we notice the
pattern but it's difficult to know what
that looks like in real life until you
see it happening before your very eyes
and right now we're seeing it happen
before our very eyes everybody has
noticed this strange group of pundits we
could call them who are all coming up
from the margin quite literally you know
from the margin they're rising out of
internet culture and they are using
television and mainstream media with
like with guerrilla tactics and with
searing laughter and it's been really
fascinating to watch them come up and
what's strange is if you look at that
group of people together they're like
they're a seriously ragtag bunch of
folks there they're there if you look at
them as a group they're the type of
people that would never in a normal
world be seen as together and it's
hilarious like I never thought the end
of the world would be so funny
so when you see like you know like
liberal gay married dave rubin spend an
hour talking to evangelical conservative
steven crowder like what is happening
you have Orthodox Jew you know like
argument assassin ben shapiro who is on
the podcast of like a weed smoking MMA
fighter and they talked for three hours
and it's like what is going on and
they're not fighting they're actually
having a civil discussion
what about sargon of akkad on Joe Rogan
Sargon is like he's a glorified troll he
came out he comes out of gamergate and
like here he is on the most popular
podcast in the world and we're listening
here boy we're like listening and it's
crazy and you know and it's not just
happening online in those strange media
figures rising up it's also happening in
the public
it's like strange but like all of you
you a strange group of people like this
strange group of people that somehow
feel like they're on the same side for
some reason and in any normal world they
wouldn't be like in what world does an
evangelical pastor become all excited
about a discussion between Jordan
Peterson and Camille Paglia like that
doesn't seem like it should happen or
like some Catholic college student comes
up to you and he's talking about you
know this he's talking about the
political commentary of a Satanist like
sticks and hammer six-six-six and you're
like this world should not exist you
feel like you you just want to tilt your
head and despair but you can't because
you're laughing too much so even myself
I I jumped into the fray it seems I
started making these youtube videos this
year on symbolism and how it connects to
the modern world and and I mean I am I'm
an orthodox icon Carver at the base I
mean I spend half of my days literally
in the Middle Ages and that you know
who's supporting me on patreon atheists
like what is happening like I went I was
kind of browsing through the people were
supporting me on pay
and this one guy he's supporting my
channel and God Saad at the same time
like God Saad spends half of his waking
hours making fun of religion it's like
how does that even possible and the main
like and the mainstream media they they
they have no idea what's happening like
like a bunch of headless chickens
they're running around they don't even
know that their heads have been chopped
off and they're running around and
they're bumping into everything and
leavening they're you they're just
leveling their usual insults and it'll
have no shred of forethought to notice
that the world is upside down and they
end up calling Jews Nazis and then they
end up calling gays homophobic and
they're like calling people you know who
owe themselves are are married to to to
immigrants and minorities that your eggs
and a phobic it's absolutely mad like I
said you just can't you can't you just
have to laugh you can't stop laughing so
in trying to find the best archetypal
story let's say to describe this process
like how is it that this crazy marginal
group of people are coming together like
the the I had a few ideas like the first
idea that I thought of was the story of
King David in the Bible but in the story
of King David when David was this secret
and hidden King and no one knew that he
was the King yet you know the actual
King Saul became this tyrant and a very
disturbed figure who was like trying to
like raise dead people just very
disturbing person and he's trying to you
know like kill David with his Lance
so David ended up hiding in a cave and
he gathered this ragtag group of thieves
and debtors and he had this like crazy
band of guys and and then he sometimes
even pretended that he was fighting for
the other side he pretended that he was
fighting for the enemies of Israel while
secretly he wasn't so David was the
first larper
but in the end I mean the Oh David also
had somebody acted he acted like he was
a crazy man
then he's dancing naked like just nutty
stuff you know but at the end of the
story he restores the kingship and he
restores the ark to Jerusalem and from
that time on Jerusalem became the center
and the let's say the the focus point of
the of the country and and until today
but of all the all those ancient stories
the best is is Robin Hood I mean there
are numerous versions of Robin Hood but
the basic thread is is the same so the
true King Richard the Lionheart is away
and his feckless brother John Lackland
has taken over I mean and John Lackland
he's a he's a resentful guy like he
knows that he shouldn't be king so who's
seen the Disney version of Robin Hood
right that's the best Prince John ever
the first snowflake like he's he's he's
sucking his thumb and calling for his
mom
and in that story the noble spirits they
have to become thieves and outliers they
have to disguise themselves the sly man
becomes the hero then they hide in the
margins they hide in the forest and when
you see them they are this like ragtag
bunch of peculiar characters people who
probably wouldn't have fit together in
any other circumstance you've got that
like the you know the enforcer Little
John and you got like the clergy Friar
Tuck guy and and will scarlet and will
scarlet is Milo by the way and these new
these new media pundits these these
people I'm telling you about they're
coming up in the meat of this new rag
tag team this new band of merry men they
have a laughter and a kind of brash
boldness which is the only answer when
you're facing an offended lady who's
clutching her pearls how is it like the
left is offended all the time I have
this this image of resetting the movie
Footloose at Yale on Halloween and
having like Kevin Bacon in a sombrero
like trying to like loosen up the new
Puritans
so what is it that unites this new group
of pundits like this ragtag team of of
bear of merry men what is it that
they're carry coming bringing out of the
dark corners of the internet an
alternative media well its speech of
course freedom of speech opposition to
political correct tyranny but in its
best moment it's also truth a desire to
to work out what's true even though it
can be painful at least willing to put
out your arguments against your opponent
in an honest debate or discussion and
not try to try to
shut down whoever disagrees with you now
since the last year I've been kind of
making videos and doing events with
jordan peterson and there so those who
have characterized me is like the jordan
peterson sidekick and it's like that's
fine there are worse things to be in
life but to be honest there's a whole
lot of things that i disagree with with
jordan like there's a whole lot of basic
premises that we don't necessarily i - i
but there is a reason why i have aligned
myself with his project a reason why i
aligned myself with him even before this
crazy pronoun gate and that is because
he aligns speech and truth with purpose
and virtue and when you put those
together speech truth purpose and virtue
what you have is logos logos is the
greek word for word logos the word is
the basis of the Western tradition it
means word but it also implies truth and
reason reason in both ways that we use
that word like reason as the the purpose
of something like the reason why he's
wearing a crown is because he is king
but also reason in the sense of logic
you can see the word logos in the word
logic
logos in all its fullness fullness I
believe should be the rallying call of
this new ragtag bunch of heroes you know
jacques derrida the famous postmodern
critic he saw that as the main crux of
the West
he called it out he said that the center
of the West was logos and he used that
to decry the West as being logo centric
but he only saw the logos as this
imposition of power the imposition of a
center of meaning through a kind of
violence on the margin but we have to
understand that logos reason purpose is
the reason why there's anything at all
is the marker of all ident any
identities any object anything has a
center which holds it together
to be a pen it could be happiness it
could be anything
it's what whole the multiplicities of
those things into what makes you see it
as one that's that's the logos and so
logos is not only the center of meaning
but it's also the mediator of all these
differences the mediator of all the the
opposites and so as the mediator of
these extremes the mediator of the two
poles but also all that's in between
that's what it's what rallies what is
fragmented an idiosyncratic into a
common purpose and a common goal but
it's also what preserves multiplicity
and variation within the horrors of the
horizon of that Center so for example
like when Justin Trudeau says something
like diversity is our strength we can
see that he's only calling one side of
the coin he's calling for completeness
without thinking of coherence
diversity without unity is not strength
in fact it is the very definition of
weakness and the call to unbounded
diversity as an invitation to the other
extreme the pendulum those two things
coexist it's a call to the other extreme
to manifest itself extreme coherence and
purity and what what was it that they
said in charlottesville blood and soil
you will not replace us and unity
without diversity is also not strength
it is brittle and eventually it shatters
none of this is helping so my call is
that true logo centrism what de da D
righted is diversity in unity it's the
need to bow our idiosyncrasies to the
common person to a common good and also
know that that common good will not
swallow all of our particularity Xin to
absolute conformity logo centrism is
balanced I even dared to go as far to
say that logo centrism is love and
that's why I think that as this new
media uprising these new media pundits
continue to flourish all of those that
rally around them commit themselves to
speech to truth but also to purpose and
virtue and I think that logo centrism is
the is the best name for that and it's
the best name first of all because
because it's because to use that name
will annoy the hell out of
postmodernists my kid will drive them
absolutely insane and you can have just
a bit bit more laughter let's say a few
more waves of that but also plunging
into the waters into strange hybrid
amphibious forms that we've all taken
finding that
old and pathfinding the truth the
purpose of our lives of our families and
walking on that path of logos we will
become upright forthright and active
participants in our own lives and in our
community and in our country and
whatever it is that can rally that
rallies us together and I believe that
that's the the only way to get out of
this mess
so thank you
[Applause]